[Music]
we'll spend the next half hour talking a
little bit about agile
ai and how um my team has been taking
the latest research uh into production
so xenoblade
i do go by z if that's easier so
maybe just to set the stage here um as
you guys have
all been experiencing ai is the
landscape that's
very daunting because everyone wants it
right everyone wants to make
their applications smarter um but
as customers are trying to implement
these different technologies different
ai
capabilities um they're facing a lot of
difficulties
everything from not understanding how to
scope these projects not necessarily
feeling like they have the skill sets
needed in-house to to build these
products
etc so um
at salesforce the einstein
uh team is focused on really bringing ai
for crm
um it's integrated within the salesforce
platform it's trusted
making sure that we uphold our
transparency and ethical standards that
we have
and as daniel mentioned um so my team
really focuses
on the deep learning model specifically
in computer vision
and um natural language processing
so um just as a few examples here
um everything from image classification
to ocr on the vision side
and um sentiment intent as well as ner
on the language side
what's really cool about these products
is that
um these are the same underlying
products are used internally by our
teams
so um the nlp that i just mentioned is
used by
our internal einstein bots team
to be able to drive conversational ai
excuse me as well as by our marketing
team
for emotion detection for example and
this same technology these same services
are also
used by our customers directly
um so for example uh for rmi uh
automating charging of cases
or survey analysis and the same thing is
true
oh um and one more use case i guess um
that i'm a big fan of is uh we worked
with
this visualization uh company putting
um to analyze for example congressman
data so you can see that the range of
use cases
is pretty um is pretty broad
and the same thing goes for the vision
side right so
the same api is the same
models and services that we make
available um
our internal teams are using so for
example marketing cloud social studios
or our consumer goods team is using it
for retail execution
and then we have customers um using
these products directly
and so i just wanted to share that to
give you guys some context um
you know as i'm sharing kind of our
process um as well as
um as some takeaways um
to give you guys some insights about how
the products that we've been working on
are being used both internally as well
as externally by customers
um so with that um let me talk
a little bit through how our team works
so hopefully you guys can gain some
insights from that as well
so as daniel mentioned earlier half my
team
is the salesforce research team and
they're literally focused
on advancing the state of the art
in ai for example in language and vision
which we'll talk about specifically
today
so for example in nlp we have
people working on everything from
question and answering machine
translation
summarization etc and you know
these teams are working on
literally you know publishing papers
talking at conferences
and moving the state of the art
for what's possible in a.i one such
example
that came out a few months ago was uh
the multi-task question and answering so
as you guys might have might be aware in
nlp
um we tend to break down you know the
way that we
tackle nlp problems right usually is by
tackling and breaking them down
into specific tasks and focusing on one
task
at a time um with this latest model um
we were able to um bring in
ten tasks uh under one model um that's
able to also generalize
and learn from different domains um
use zero shot learning and really be
able to expand from the
original uh training data that's
provided
into a variety of different tasks as we
saw in the previous
um in the previous slide so with these
kind of
uh advances that the team is working on
we then use that
to um to
bake these latest technologies into our
products so for example i mentioned
sentiment or intent
so let's dive a little bit into intent
for example and how
our team is you know focusing on
uh taking the latest breakthroughs in ai
into
some of these models that we are
providing to customers
so with intent uh for example
um one of you know we come to to our
research team
to our applied research team and we're
like hey we need
to be able to train these models more
efficiently or
we need to be able to um
to provide these models in additional
languages
and so they work on
running experiments evaluating different
state-of-the-art models coming up with
new
algorithms to tackle some of these
problems
and once they've identified that hey we
have a solution
then we work with our data science and
engineering team to bring these into
market
um so another great example that we had
recently
is you know we you know our intent model
which is basically a text classification
model
um allows customers to define you know
their categories
their intense provides some data and
then it trains
it trains a model on that um now the
negative data set or you know the other
category is something that was becoming
a very big pain point for our customers
because as you can imagine for example
in a chat conversation
trying to train a model to understand
you know other or everything else that
somebody could talk about that isn't in
the scope of what you want
your bot to necessarily handle um can be
very complex and a very daunting task
and so basically worked with our
applied research team to devise an
algorithm to be able to
automate that process and so use the
data
that customers provide us to then
automatically
generate this other or out of domain
category
out of the box and so our customers
don't have to do that
and so this is working really well and
um you know once we validate that hey we
have an algorithm that's
um that has potential from our applied
research team
we then work with our data science team
to validate it on
you know real world use cases and then
um we then pilot it with customers
before we roll this out
fully to everyone and this is one
example that just
you know got rolled out actually earlier
this week
two more examples as you guys are
probably
very aware often times with these deep
learning models
the hurdle of adoption is often with the
data
and not having sufficient data to be
able to train these models
and so um right now with our team um
you know we've we've identified these
problems and so we turn once again to
our applied research team and we're like
hey
can we address this problem and so
we're looking right now at um for
example
looking at historical chat transcripts
and being able
to find similarities with example
already are provided by customers and
then surface those
um to the admin who's training these
models to be able to easily add
a bunch of examples um another
approach that we're taking is
synthetically generating a bunch of data
and so you know data augmentation
there's a lot of
different data augmentation techniques
um
our applied research and data science
team you know focuses
on evaluating different techniques and
the trade-offs
um and then once we have something that
looks promising
we then try that out with a few
customers a few
um a few if we build a few models
validate that it works
then we pilot it with customers and then
and then we roll it out
more widely um and
same thing when i'll talk about the
vision it's a very similar process
where we basically uh you know
have people on our team on the research
side
that are working on advancing the state
of the art here as well
so looking at visual description
so for example if they're given a
picture
if the model is given a picture um it'll
provide a natural language
uh description of what's in the picture
and so you can see here
a little girl sitting on a bench holding
an umbrella
and some of the cool stuff with computer
vision is you can see where the model
is focusing to generate certain words
another great example here is visual
question and answering so you provide
the model
with a picture and a question
and um the model will then provide a
response
and i love this example here because you
can see that
you know what colors are the bananas not
only can you see that
the model is focusing on bananas it's
not understanding what bananas are
but responds green and so it's not using
you know general knowledge about
bananas and responding yellow but really
you know using
the the image that's provided here to be
able to answer that question
um visual object detection is another
um another um
area where our team is focusing a lot of
work on
um so being able to identify
objects or parts of objects within an
image um actually last year we won first
place
in one of the biggest object detection
competitions
and so once again um these latest ai
breakthroughs then feed into
the products that we make available to
customers
so whether that's image classification
object detection
or ocr so i'll i'll walk you guys
through
just as another point of example here uh
kind of how ocr came about and kind of
our process
our journey through um taking it from
you know an idea all the way uh to to
market
into production and adoption so
um a few years ago basically what
happened
um you know we were at dream force which
is one of our sales first big
conferences
um and our biggest conference actually
and um i had i brought the
head of applied research with me to a
few of these customer meetings
and in multiple of these meetings we
were hearing from customers
this demand for being able to read text
and images
and the use cases varied a little bit
right but there was this general theme
of wanting to be able to digitize
um these uh the text that's uh
that's available whether it's on vin
numbers uh receipts
uh tables etc um and
and our head of applied research was
like hey z like i think we can
we can solve this better than what's out
there in the market and so i was like
okay great
go ahead let's let's put somebody on
this and try to see if we can
um develop an algorithm a model that's
going to be able to perform better than
than than what's out there in the market
that differentiates us
on the specific use cases that we care
about and so
once you know we had part of our team
working on that problem
once we've identified okay yes we have a
solution that could work here
we then you know worked with our data
science and
engineering team to be able to serve
these models
and provide them to our customers but
even within that
you know we we take it step by step so
initially the first version of our ocr
model you know was really just about
text and images
and we also provided the bounding boxes
to where that text is in the image
and then the next iteration of that was
the text in the image
and the associated entities and then
the version after that is text and image
and
the associated cell if it's in a table
now what we're working on is
standard form so these forms that are
you know
standardized um and it's basically
taking ocr to the next level
where you're not only detecting the the
data or the text that's in the image but
you're also
um really doing key value pair matching
um and so once again here we start you
know with a specific set of standard
forms
before we move to okay now we're working
on custom forms
as well as handwriting and so you can
see here um
from the very beginning you know we we
broke the problem down into smaller
pieces
and really tried to tackle one step at a
time instead of trying to go directly
being like
oh you know the big problem is
handwriting we should start there
and so really kind of building our core
expertise step by step as we kind of
um evolve and grow our models from there
and our customer demand
um and so basically uh as you can see
with both the vision and the language
team it's really this
cycle that happening where you know
product or customers
are coming up with these are telling us
hey can you solve this problem for us
we then go to our applied research team
like okay can we solve this problem once
we've identified that we can solve this
problem
then we work with our data science and
engineering team to be able to
um host and serve these models
in um in production and making sure that
you know they meet the trust and
security standards
that we expect etc and you know i spent
a lot of time talking about the research
side of things but
um there's a lot of work that goes into
this engineering
and making sure that you're able to host
and scale your models as well
um and so really this is a cycle that
that's happened
uh that's happening that's really you
know taking breaking things up step by
step
and making sure to kind of have this
pipeline that kind of
feeds into each other so
with that so and i've kind of covered
our process of how
we kind of take things from research
into production
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
talk a little bit about
agile ai and really how
not only you've seen this in some of our
examples but really how our customers
are
being successful with um with
deploying ai models in their
applications
so i'm assuming everyone here
is familiar with waterfall versus
agile in in development
life cycles of products um so for
example if you know
the goal was to build the car in
waterfall you'd start with a tire
and then the motor and then the you know
and then you'd continue
step by step and a few years later you
would have a car that can take you from
point a to point b
in agile right and agile development you
break that down a little differently
right where you're like okay my point my
goal is to get from point a from
b ideally i want a car but i'm gonna
start with a skateboard
i'm gonna then you know go to a bicycle
motorcycle and eventually i'll get a car
um and the value here is that at each
step of the process you're able to get
feedback from your customers right
so you guys are familiar with this now
um
basically um for ai models developing
these models
taking a very similar approach is really
key
so i'm going to walk you guys through a
very simplistic uh example to illustrate
this point but i think
you know has really helped in uh my
conversations with customers
help make things click for them so let's
say that
um we wanted to create a model that
understood all the fruits in the world
right
in waterfall i would basically
start by creating a list of all the
fruits in the world
then i would collect data for all the
fruits in the world then i would train a
model then i would improve it and you
know a few years later or after my
project has
no longer any funding you would have a
model right now
the that's just a very you know you're
front loading a lot of work
and putting a lot of risk very early on
so
doing agile ai basically is thinking
about
how can you break this up into what is
your minimal viable data set
right so yes i want to get to a model
that understands all the fruits in the
world
but i'm going to start with just apples
and pears
that's the most common fruits uh i'm
french though
that's the most common fruit that people
use and so um
i'm just going to start and focus just
on those and what's going to happen at
first is
i'm not going to have a lot of data so
all the examples i've trained my model
on
are red apples and uh and green pairs
and so
the first time my model sees a green
apple
it's actually going to say this is a
pair um and so
um what's what you need to make sure to
do here is include
a feedback loop right so having a
mechanism
in in your process um and depending on
your application this might be at
different times
but making sure to have uh some
at some points in your process the
ability for
for some for someone to correct the
prediction that the model made
and say actually no this is an apple and
so what's going to happen is that over
time
your model is going to get data that's
more representative
of the different use cases that it's
going to see in the world
and so when it gets for example a yellow
apple even though you might not have
ever seen a yellow apple and have been
able to generalize enough the concept of
apple and pear
that's able to correctly predict that
this is an apple right
um now the other cool thing
is um that you can do here is thinking
about
you know we talked earlier about out of
domain or other sometimes called
negative data set right
so um the reality is your model is going
to encounter
things that you know you haven't
necessarily trained at on right
and this happens in almost all use cases
unless you're in a very constrained
domain
um but what's going to happen here if if
i've trained my model only on apples and
pears
is that it's going to try to predict one
of these two categories right
so it's going to see an orange and it's
going to say no this is an apple and so
what you want to be able to do
is add this catch-all bucket this other
category
and so uh when you know somebody sends a
picture of an orange
um it'll be able to categorize this as
other
right um and so this is not you know
apple's repairs and it doesn't you know
reduce the ability for your model to
understand apples and pears
even though there's a bunch of other
fruits in the world right it's still
able to
start understanding and getting a good
understanding of apples and pears now
the cool thing about this
other category is then you can use that
as well
to um to retrain to
to add additional categories to your
model so just
this is a simplistic dashboard here that
you can see
for example if it was an admin that
would be providing the feedback loop in
this uh scenario
right i'm sorry about that
um you can see here the
the admin you know these are here the
inputs the images that the
users are sending this is what the model
is predicting
um and then this is the feedback that
you're giving it and so you can see here
at first the model was uh you know you
were giving it oranges
it was saying it's apples the admin
corrected that to say
other and eventually it was able to
predict other correctly
now the thing that you can do here as
well as an admin is
realize that hey i actually am seeing a
lot of examples of people sending
oranges and so what i can do is create
this additional category now
in my model that's oranges and the great
thing is i already
have the data to see this category
now um this is you know a very
simplistic example that kind of
ran you through to think about um
because it really illustrates the point
of how you can
iteratively um iteratively grow your
models
uh step by step um and this holds true
for anything right so
for any uh any uh ai model that you're
trying to build
for example for chat bots um what we
tell our customers
is you know don't try to automate
everything that your agents are doing if
you start your project by trying to do
that
you know your the amount of effort
needed to get something out the door
is just so big and so you're not going
to start seeing roi for a long time
and you know your sponsors your
executive sponsors are not going to
necessarily be happy with
uh with your ability to deliver write a
chatbot if that's the case
so instead focus on you know maybe the
two to five
uh categories of things that come up the
most often
password resets uh changing your order
status or changing your order delivery
uh location right so just focus on
the top you know few items
that um that your agents are seeing more
often so pick just a few a handful
five um and build your model there and
with this other category
you're then able to look at that and
review that
and iteratively grow your model from
there
so that's agile ai
maybe i'll take some time here to cover
maybe
three more takeaways um that we've seen
um so the first one is um
data this is often the most uh
you know the biggest hurdle that
customers have of like
how do i get started i don't have the
data or i don't know how to
to train these models um so a few things
here
um if you have it i'd say use it
but make sure that it's qa that you go
through the step
of uh cleaning that data uh because
if you if you feed your model data
that's not clean it's
your your model is not gonna work well
right and so even if you have the data
make sure to
um to clean it up before you use it
a second um thing that we recommend is
try to see if you can find data sets
online
um i i do think that we're seeing more
and more of a trend
of uh data sets uh
as um as a
as a channel for people to uh um
to be able to acquire these data sets
online you can find public data sets
that are free but then there's also in
the commercial space
more and more data sets that are
available for purchase as well and so
that might be a great opportunity
depending on your use case
and then finally um
[Music]
creating your data uh it's often not as
much work as you think it
is uh the biggest hurdle often here is
that it's
nobody's job um and so you know you kind
of get blocked but
if you use agile ai and if you scope
your projects correctly
where you reduce the amount of data that
you need to a minimum
creating that data um if it comes to it
should not
you know should not be as huge of a
project it is is
i'll tell you um in multiple projects
that we've had at
um at salesforce on my team the first
iteration of these applications
uh you know i've sat in rooms and
created the data
for for training these models right so
for assistance applications for a bunch
of different use cases
um sometimes you know it just takes
taking a few hours
few weeks and actually collecting or
generating this data yourself
so don't be scared of doing that um and
then
really thinking about the whole pipeline
so um thinking about
making sure that as you're building new
products that you're storing your data
in a way that in the future if you want
to
that you'd be able to use that data
easily to train your models
um
another uh takeaway that i think is
really important we talked a little bit
about
it earlier and when we're talking about
agile ai
but this is this notion of feedback
loops um
it's really important to think about in
your process
as you're developing your application
what points
will you be able to have uh whether it's
your end user whether it's an
admin whether it's somebody on your team
but it needs to be somebody in the
process that is able to
review and and monitor how well the
model is performing and be able to take
the um the areas where the model is not
working very well and use that to
to to improve your model over time right
so add the misclassifications like
correctly label them and add them back
into your training data and then as we
talked about using this other category
to be able to see what actually your
customers are
are wanting to use your model for and
using that
other category to be able to seed your
data set for additional
you know categories and labels there
and then um finally um
the last point i'll make here is that um
you know
as we are democratizing ai as we're
making it more accessible for everyone
to train their models
um it is our responsibility to make sure
that we're
educating people right um similar to how
we're having you know
citizen developers we're seeing a trend
towards citizen data scientists
where we're really making it easy uh to
be able to train
um these models these deep learning
models um
but we also then need to make sure that
we're training people not only giving
them
access to the tools to do this but we're
also training them to understand
how their model is performing and then
also
what the ethical uh considerations are
of their of their models right um
because
it is important you know it's easy to
you know now that we've automated a lot
of these things it's either just take a
bunch of data
click a button say train your model and
then just say okay start using this
um but you know there's a lot of work
that needs to go into making sure
that you know your data is
representative that your data doesn't
have any bias
um making sure that the way that your
model is being used
is actually being done in a way that is
impacting your processes positively
and is not discriminating uh against
certain classes
or races etc so
it is our responsibility to make sure
you know
as we're democratizing ai as we're
making it easier
um that these concepts in data science
around
understanding how your model is
performing understanding the intended
and unintended consequences of your
model um
are you know are passed on and are
trained and
uh and we educate people on these
concepts as well
um because you know we can't just give
them the tools and and just
expect um everyone to to be able to
to drive right we need to be able to
teach them how to drive to make sure
um we don't have a lot of accidents on
the road basically
um and so with that um
i think we're about at time um
i'll i'll maybe finish by saying you
know um the best way to predict the
future is to create it
uh i know ai has been uh you know
hyped and and something that we've been
talking about
for a while but we are still very much
in the early days of starting to see
um the latest research breakthroughs go
into production
and improve the way society is
is run and so i'm really excited to see
how
you know we continue to leverage uh
these latest breakthroughs to
hopefully improving society for for the
whole
of everyone